ladies and Gentlemen please welcome
Samuel
Le we come in with nothing and we're
going to come out with nothing our short
life here on Earth is just a
glimpse hi just listen to Samuel lead's
presentation's been fantastic five key
point to to success Financial Freedom
you need to get his film bless you see
you soon this is probably the best
presentation
I've ever heard on fin this is the
second time we've had Samuel speak at
one of our conferences he was excellent
last time and he was excellent this time
bring him along because he's got great
knowledge um and he presents in a really
humorous way our guys were really
engaged we I was really impressed with
the amazing value and content Samuel
gave across the bill so really great
speak listen to what he's got to
say